après même harcèlement coups de pied
coups de cymbale eich ocz un invité de
marque à plaisir m naoki au 8e dan de
karaté était présent ce samedi 9 février
au palais des sports
le karatéka restait cinq heures sur
place pour animer un stage organisé par
le karaté club plaisir ouah je transmets
pas mafieuses et l'eau de vie assez les
mêmes techniques technique se déplacer
dépassement parce que karaté on n'est
pas encore donc pour toucher il faut
souder pas s'ils vont très vite et dans
les coups de poing coups nos pays le
rendez-vous a permis à une cinquantaine
de participants venus de plaisir de ses
environs de découvrir une nouvelle
approche de cet art martial japonais
il est 8e dan et les ceintures noires
aussi vient du japon je crois oui et
donc au japon ben c'est pas la même
chose je pense
il nous apporte un savoir-faire des
techniques des gestes qui sont
extrêmement importants pour nous
simplement de façon très simple et très
ludiques philosophiques m naoki omi a
également profité de ce rendez-vous pour
revenir sur l'impact de l'âge dans le
monde du sport et notamment sur le
karaté au étant jeune on est un peu fou
lieu mais en vieillissant bien on adapte
en fonction de sa morphologie de sa
santé mais par contre on note technique
va s'affiner et est de plus en plus
efficaces m now qui dit régulièrement
sans le trahir
il dit souvent je je suis moon ou plus
puissants car en jeu fait moins
d'efforts qu'avant après m'être naoki
omis un nouvel expert national en karaté
devrait revenir à plaisir le 18 mai
prochain